[Applaudissements]
je ne me marier par et toi tu fait
partie
la balle est joué d'avancé
on n'y peut rien changer tout dépend de
ta naissance mais moi je ne suis pas
bien payés alors enfin le plein
qu'on soit en mai et la rue n'est pas du
sud un énorme en est mais moi je vis
dans le manche et ça se voit pas mais
l'accent n'est pas exactement le palace
tout cas venu que bousquet
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas beau ça
exemple à la
ça vous voulez chez les pilotes oui
est-ce que c'est pas non c'est pas mon
point le plus sensible
donc pour être nue avec de la paille
avec des bottes moi tout nu mais
vraiment tout nu et se passerait rien
c'est vraiment comme marcheurs à toi tu
me demandez pas ce que vous n'êtes pas
puissants
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour d
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]